well back on on sun that uh was
Professor Norman FY listened to all that
was Douglas Murray Douglas your response
to that
interview uh several things I've
followed the career of Norman finlin for
many years um he's notorious for having
destroyed his career by among other
things weaponizing his parents being in
the Holocaust to use his career to
attack Israel in particular uh I think
all societies produce a type of
sociopath and psychopath and I do think
the Norman finline is just such a person
if I can give just one example he
repeatedly in that interview referred to
Gaza as a concentration camp gazer is no
such thing as a concentration camp and
Norman finlin knows that very very well
every single Jew was removed from Gaza
forcibly in 2005 by the Israeli
government in 2006 the people of Gaza
had an election and they elected Hamas
Hamas proceeded to kill fat and other
Palestinian who did not agree with Hamas
and if anyone is responsible for making
Gaza into a prison camp it is Hamas that
uses places like the shifa hospital as
torture chambers for Palestinians now
here's another Oddity about it he kept
saying concentration camp about Gaza do
you peers know anybody who got out of a
concentration camp in
1945 and proceeded to go next door and
behead and rape everyone they could find
I don't but only Norman finl finds these
kinds of comparisons to make and makes
them willfully and by the way and shame
on him for this what we just heard was
Holocaust Denial in real time he
pretends we don't know what happened on
the 7th of October we do know we do know
and if he doesn't believe the reports he
reads and if he doesn't believe all of
the international media he should have
come with me this morning to the
Pathology Department here in tele AV
where they are still trying to work out
who the bodies are that are arriving I
was standing this morning in Tel Aviv in
the Mory with the doctors who are trying
to work out the identities still of the
people killed that day there is so
little of some of them peers that they
can't even extract DNA from them there
is so little of them that sometimes it
turns out what was thought to be the
charred remains of one person is the
remains of two people people arrive in
bags peers they arrive in bags with
little bits of what is left of their
body and maybe a bit of a mobile phone
there was the skull of a what I said
that must be a child's skull and one of
the experts there in the Mory said
actually we don't know because the fire
in the house that the Hamas lit was so
intense in its heat it could have been a
young man's skull that was warped into a
smaller size by the heat so if Norman
finl practicing his Holocaust denialism
in real time actually wants to practice
any of the academic Pursuit he has spent
his career not pursuing then I would
urge him to go like I did and see the
body bags in the Mory here and see what
Hamas did that day it is disgusting that
Norman finlin uses his late parents to
defame Israel to De pretend that Israel
are the Nazis in this situation all
societies produce sick individuals but
very few people have been produced who
are quite as sick as Norman finklestein
would you ever debate with
him I said to you I refuse and I refuse
for one straightforward reason is that I
know a very very few people I wouldn't I
I would say I don't debate with but
Norman finlin is one of them most people
I know in Academia stopped having
anything to do with him many decades ago
when he wrote his book The Holocaust
industry in 2000 claiming that the Jews
were using the Holocaust to sort of make
money from and so on most people wanted
to be nowhere near such a feted
individual I don't think he's somebody
you can debate with because I do not
want to debate with a Holocaust denier
in real time any more than I would
debate with a holocaust denier who was
denying the last Holocaust this was the
biggest murder of Jew since the
Holocaust and shame on Norman finlin for
trying to pretend that that didn't
happen or happened differently in real
time it's disgust in Douglas as always
thank you very much indeed for your
powerful contribution tonight I greatly
appreciate
it